The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK so
let's start on the material.
We're following the
V-model and the empty boxes
are getting fewer and
fewer every week here.
So we're on the
right side moving up
toward lifecycle
management and operations.
And today's topic is via
V&V, verification validation.
And I also want
to discuss the FRR
as one of the key milestones,
and that's the flight readiness
review.
If you're not building
something that flies,
this is your launch to market,
right launch to market review.
Are you ready to launch your
project or product to market?
The outline is-- we have
quite a few things to cover.
So first of all, I want
to drill into verification
and validation.
What's the difference?
What is their role?
What's their position
in the lifecycle?
Then we'll spend quite a bit of
time on the issue of testing.
What kind of testing is done?
Why is it done?
We'll talk about aircraft
testing, flight testing,
we'll talk about spacecraft
testing, but also some caveats.
Testing is not always the--
it's not free of challenges
and difficulties.
Then I want to talk about
technical risk management,
which is often covered in
classes on project management,
but I think it's essential
here as well as a system
engineer to have a good grasp
on technical risk management.
So I'll cover the risk
matrix, the Iron Triangle,
cost, schedule, scope,
and risk, and then
I added a small section
on system safety, which is
a very important topic as well.
And we'll finish up with
discussing the FRR, the flight
readiness review.
So the readings
related to this lecture
are sections 5.3 and 5.4
in the handbook, the System
Engineering Handbook,
and then there's
a couple of appendices
there, Appendix E And I
that are very, very helpful.
And at least one of these
I'll mention in the lecture.
Plus one of the papers, and this
is a paper about a decade old--
and I know a lot of work has
been done on this since then,
but this is a paper
by Professor Leveson.
Nancy Leveson was
a colleague of mine
here at MIT who's really an
expert in systems safety.
So the system safety
model that she's developed
is the subject of that paper.
OK, so let's talk about V&V,
verification and validation,
and how they fit together.
You've seen this diagram
before, but I just
want to talk through it
in some detail again.
So the idea is you
start your project,
you're undertaking,
in the upper left.
You do your
stakeholder analysis.
Who are the stakeholders,
the customers, beneficiaries,
the regulators, the suppliers,
the partners on the project?
So you really have to do a
good job doing your stakeholder
analysis then in order to
write your requirements.
And I do have to say I've
been very pleased, especially
with your assignment A-2.
You really dug into those 47
requirements for canned set.
You grouped them, you scrubbed
them, you did a great job.
And the idea is that for
each of these requirements,
you also have target values.
There are certain
thresholds or target values
that have to be achieved.
And then you actually
do the development.
You do the conceptual
design, the detailed design,
and that's written here
as functional deployment.
In other words, especially
for the functional
and the performance
requirements,
how will you actually
implement those,
embody those, in technology,
hardware, software,
and so forth.
So that's your intended
function, your concept,
and then you're implemented
design solution.
Now the question
is, do you actually
satisfy A, the
requirements, and do you
satisfy your stakeholders?
And it is possible that you
satisfy the requirements,
but not the stakeholders.
So the way to
think about this is
we're going to close the loop.
In fact, we're going
to close two loops.
An inner loop-- and
I put testing here.
Testing is really
one of the ways
to verify whether you
meet requirements.
There's other ways too,
but testing is often
the most important.
So we close this inner loop.
So what we ask is--
we test our
implemented solution,
our implemented design, and ask
the question, did we deliver?
Did we actually satisfy
the requirements
as they were written?
Do we satisfy the requirements
And are these attainable?
Were these requirements
attainable?
So this loop here, this inner
loop, is the verification loop.
You verify whether you design
as implemented satisfies
the requirements as written.
That's what verification is.
And then there's
an outer loop where
you take your implemented
design solution,
and you essentially
bring it all the way back
to the stakeholders.
And usually that also
means you're employing it
in a realistic environment,
like in the environment
that the stakeholders will
actually use the system,
not in a pristine
lab environment.
And you have the stakeholders
try out your system
and see whether they're
satisfied, whether this
meets their original intent.
You remember the CONOPS,
concept of operations?
Can you actually do
the CONOPS the way
you had envisioned it in
a realistic environment?
And that's what we
call validation.
And that's the outer loop.
You see the difference?
So a lot of people who don't
know system engineering who
have never been exposed to this
when they hear verification
and validation, they think it's
basically two different words
for the same thing.
It is it is different,
it's not the same thing.
And then if you successfully
verify and validate,
you end the SE process and
you deliver, which is good.
So this is something
I pulled out
from the handbook,
which is the differences
between verification
and validation.
And I'm just
summarizing this here.
So one way to ask is, was the
end product realized right?
Meaning, did you
do the right thing?
Or did you implement
it correctly?
So verification is often
done during development,
so you verify
components, subsystems,
you check if the
requirements are met.
Typically, verification is done
in a laboratory environment,
or on a test stand, or
some environment that
allows you to very carefully
control the test conditions.
And verification tends to
be component and subsystem
centric.
OK, and then validation
is the question
was the right end
product realized?
Did you actually
build the right thing?
Did you deploy the
right solution?
This is often
done-- so validation
focuses more on during or
after system integration.
It's typically done in a real or
simulated mission environment.
You check if your
stakeholder intent is met.
And it's often done
using the full-up system.
It's difficult to do validation
on a subsystem basis alone.
Typically, validation
implies you've
got to use the whole
system to do it.
Or, you basically
use dummy subsystems.
You basically replace
the actual subsystems
you're going to
have with something
temporary so that you can
go back to the stakeholder
and give them as close
to the real experience
as they'll have with
the actual system.
OK, so that's essentially
the distinction here.
So I want to do a quick
concept question on this
to see whether this point,
this distinction, came across.
So here's a link, SE9VV,
these are all caps.
And what I'm listing here
is different test activities
or different type of activities.
And I'd like you to
check the box here
whether you think
this is verification,
whether this is validation,
or you're not sure.
All right, testing and handling
of a new car in snow conditions
in Alaska.
90% of you said
this is validation,
and I would agree with this.
So many car companies, I
think all car companies,
once the vehicle has been
finished essentially,
the design, it doesn't
go to market right away.
There's a very
extensive-- usually
it's at least six months of
field testing of a new vehicle.
And you go to the desert
where it's very sandy and hot,
test your air conditioning
systems right at the limit.
And then you go to
really cold climates.
In Europe they go up
to Sweden and Norway.
And here we tend to go up
to Michigan, Minnesota.
And so the idea
is that you really
utilize the vehicle in
a extreme environment,
but that's realistic
of actual operation.
So I agree with this.
Frontal crash test in the lab.
Most of you said
it's verification,
and I would agree with.
So those very
standardized crash tests
that you've seen in
some of the commercials.
The vehicle is
prepared, instrumented,
you have the crash test dummies.
And then you have,
typically, there's
at least three different
kinds of crash tests.
There's frontal,
there's side impact--
like the T crash--
and then there's
a rollover tests, that are
more and more standardized.
And the test conditions
in these are there
they're highly stylized tests.
They're very prescribed
exactly the speeds, the angles,
everything is prescribed.
And real accidents, the
variability of conditions
is much, much bigger
than in these tests.
So I agree because the test
conditions are so tightly
defined and constrained, this
is verification, not validation.
Testing of a new toy
in a kindergarten.
OK, so here you're--
and this is the toy companies,
and they essentially--
before, again, they make
a big million or billion
dollar decision to
mass manufacture toys,
they will actually have
kids play with them
in realistic environments.
And so I agree with
that this is validation.
Vehicle emission testing.
Obviously, this was the big
Volkswagen scandal that we had.
So basically, what this
cheating that happened
is essentially software that was
embedded in the vehicle, such
that when the vehicle
experienced exactly the test
conditions of these drive
cycles that are very well known,
very well defined, the
vehicle would internally
switch or reconfigure
to a verification mode
and really emphasize
low emissions
at the expense of fuel economy.
And as soon as the
vehicle would detect
that it's in a more
general driving conditions,
it would essentially
switch that mode off.
So verification, again,
is on a dynamo in the lab.
Satellite vibration
testing on a shake table.
We'll talk about this.
This is often-- we refer
to this as shake and bake
in the spacecraft business.
The spectra, the
load spectra, that
are put into these
shaking tables
are, again, very
stylized and different
for each launch vehicle.
So here we can debate
a little bit whether--
is it closer to validation,
because the actual test
conditions are so much adapted
to each launch vehicle.
But I agree, this is primarily
a verification activity.
And then the field testing
of the Google glasses.
So you basically produce an
initial batch of your product
and then you give it
to like lead users.
You have them try it
and give you feedback.
This is much closer
to validation.
So I think by and large your
answers here are very good.
And the real
distinguishing factor
is whether this activity
happens in a lab,
in a very controlled
environment,
under stylized conditions,
or whether you're actually
going out in the field,
in a realistic mission
environment with real users
or real potential users that
are not especially knowledgeable
or not specially trained
about the system.
So, very good job.
I think most of you really
understand that distinction.
OK.
So let me talk
briefly about the--
yes, please, Veronica?
AUDIENCE: Got it today.
OK, are there any
has that really
bridged the gap that really
could be seen as both.
So I'm thinking about
products in particular
that are to be used in a
lab setting where you have
a very specific kind of user,
where meeting the requirements
is more about how
the tool is employed,
and I see the user in that
sense is part of the system.
So I'm wondering if in
a more clinical sense
there's an action that is both
validation and verification.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah,
and so you said clinical.
So I think there are situations
where the distinction is not
as sharp, not as clear.
You said clinical, so
I think in hospital,
you know for medical
equipment, like if you
think about surgical equipment
and things like this,
where it's very hard to really--
it's very hard to do
verification in a stylized way.
The only way to
really check it is
to have the equipment embedded
and used in a pilot study,
for example, in a hospital.
And in that case, because
the human is so involved,
and it's not a general
consumer product,
but it's really a
tool for specialists,
the only way to really
check your requirements
is to actually embed it
in a realistic environment
to begin with.
So whenever it's very
difficult to design,
very specific,
isolated tests where
you can check for each of
these requirements one by one,
you almost have to move
straight into validation.
And I think in medical
equipment that's often the case.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Would you say
that for a spacecraft
really true validation
isn't possible?
You have to recreate the
conditions in some way,
in some kind of a laboratory.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
I think it depends
on the novelty of
the spacecraft.
If you're launching something
like a standard communications
satellite where you've
launched dozens before,
and you know the actual pitfalls
and the operating conditions,
you've experienced
failure modes in the past
and eradicated
most of them, I do
think that you can do
a lot in verification.
But then I'll show
you one example
of a spacecraft we've
actually talked about before,
where there's going to be
a lot of residual risk.
And the first time
it's deployed,
people are going to sweat,
because there's still
a lot of unknowns
to be resolved.
OK, so let's look at the
product verification process
in particular.
This is from the--
so this is the product
verification process
from the NASA System
Engineering Handbook.
So what are the inputs?
The end product to be verified.
So you have to have the artifact
that you're going to verify.
The specified
requirements baseline,
you need this as a reference.
What are you going
to check against?
The product
verification plan which
is essentially your test plan.
What test cases are
you going to run?
How long are you
going to run them?
How many repetitions
will you do?
And then product verification
enabling products,
which would be test
software, test equipment,
things that are not part
of the product itself,
but our enabling of the
verification process.
You then, essentially,
go through this process,
and what are the outputs?
The verified end product, the
product verification results,
so these would be
test protocols,
things like this, product
verification report, and then
product verification,
any other work products
that come out of it.
So you could have, for
example, discrepancy reports.
You failed some tests.
Well, that would be
an important output.
And then the question is,
is this significant enough
that you have to go
redesign or retest?
Or is it a minor issue that
you can waive essentially
to move to the next stage?
So let me just give
you a quick example
here from my own experience
about this verified end
product.
One of the things on the
Swiss F18 program that we did
is not just by airplanes
and equipment, but also
models of the plane itself.
In particular, finite
element models, very detailed
finite element models
of the structure.
And these models
were very expensive.
Like, some of these models
were millions of dollars.
And so I got a phone call,
I was a liaison engineer
at the time in St. Louis.
I got a phone call from
Switzerland saying,
this is crazy.
How can we be charged
millions of dollars
for this particular
set of models?
And I said, yeah, that seems
pretty expensive, so I'm
going to go negotiate this.
And so I started
negotiating, and I
guess either I'm
a bad negotiator
or it was really, really clear
why these were so expensive.
The reason these models
were so expensive
because they were on the right
side not on the left side.
So every one of these models
that we were purchasing
had been verified using
actual physical tests.
So every location was guaranteed
under the load conditions
to produce a stress
and strain prediction
at that location that was
guaranteed to be correct within
plus or minus 5%.
So the model had been very
carefully calibrated and tuned
against physical reality as
opposed to a finite element
model that's just
anybody can make a model
and put some load cases
and boundary conditions on.
And you don't know how
closely does this mean.
So there's a huge
difference in value
between a product, a model that
has gone through verification
where at the end of it
there's actually a report,
there's a protocol,
there are data
that says all these features,
all these requirements
that you had against it
have actually been checked.
This is a certified product.
And that's the main
reason for the price,
because the actual
process of verification
is very, very
resource intensive.
So even though when you look at
it physically, you might say,
I can't tell the difference
between pre-verification
and post-verification because
physically it's the same.
But in actuality,
there's a huge difference
because once it's been
verified and certified
against a set of
requirements, it's
a much more valuable asset.
Does that make sense?
So keep that in mind when you
think about these products
on the right side.
Now what are the
types of verification?
So tests we'll talk about,
so you're physically testing.
But there's other ways to
do it through analysis,
through demonstration,
and through inspection.
So analysis essentially means
you're doing a calculation
with a mathematical calculation
or a simulation that
satisfies you that this
requirement is met.
And you're doing this
with the input parameters
into the simulation are
as accurate as possible
based on the physical reality
of the system you have.
But for whatever reason,
either because you
don't have the
funds for it, or you
can't simulate the operating
conditions well enough,
you have to do it
through analysis.
Demonstration essentially means
you're operating the system,
you're demonstrating the
functions that you need,
but you don't necessarily
have a lot of instrumentation
on the system.
And you don't certainly
do destructive testing.
In other words, a
demonstration simply
means you're operating
the system as intended
and demonstrating physically
that it performs its purpose.
Inspection essentially
means you are
physically inspecting
the artifact
either visually inspecting--
there's also a lot
of techniques called
NDI, nondestructive inspection
through with X-rays or eddy
current sensors.
You're checking for the
lack of manufacturing flaws
or [INAUDIBLE], whatever it is.
But inspection
essentially is you're not
physically operating
the system, but you're
inspecting the artifact to
make sure that it satisfies
a certain set of requirements.
And then testing typically means
that you're putting a stimulus
into the system.
You're operating the system
under some test conditions.
You're recording
data, which you then
analyze in terms of comparing
that to your prediction
or expected behaviors.
So these are analysis,
demonstration, inspection,
and tests.
They are all different
ways of verification.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do I
know when I'm supposed
to use more than one
type at the same time?
I mean in and or or.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah,
that's a good point.
There's no real
general rule of this,
but in general, I would say the
more crucial, the more critical
a particular requirement is to
the operation of the system,
the more intense the
verification will be.
Whether that's just
using one of these types,
you know you just run more
tests or more different tests,
or you doing a combination
of inspection and testing.
There's no there's no
general rule in terms of two
out of three, or
two out of four,
but the purpose of the V&V plan,
the verification and validation
plan is--
and you did a little
bit of this in A2.
You did a little bit of thinking
into how would we actually
verify this requirement.
The purpose of a V&V plan is to
say for each requirement which
of these four methods are we
going to use for verification,
and then actually
write down each test
that you're going to perform,
what kind of equipment
you'll use, what kind
of test conditions.
It's a lot of work.
In fact, I think
it's fair to say
that the people that do this
kind of work, verification
and validation, are
typically different people
than the people that do the
writing of the requirements
or that do the
actual design work.
This is a pretty
specialized activity
and the people are
a little different.
If you've met people who
would do testing or quality
inspection, they're
quite different.
It's a different mind set up.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: According to
what's happening in ESA,
actually this ADIT will be
imposed in the specification
prior to your proposal.
And it will give you to
a minimum requirements
to just test against.
And they will give you a rough
matrix for every requirement
line, whether it's
[? ABIT, ?] and then
you have to answer with a
validation intense plan,
usually, unless your
agency and you are defining
the specification and
you have to do it,
and it's mostly
based on experience.
And it's some people that have
really lots of knowledge that
then make these specifications.
But I think for all
of you engineers
here in the next
10 years, you'll
be just hoping that not so many
of these ADITS in the specs
you will get,
because you will have
to answer as part of the
specification actually.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, and what--
AUDIENCE: I'll just
demonstrate it.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Well, and
the point you're making,
Voelcker, is that this is
a contractual requirement.
This is not optional.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's not optional
and it has to be followed,
the pricing, right in
front of [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yes,
very good points.
So the outputs of all of
this are discrepancy reports,
if there's any discrepancy
reports, waivers,
the verified product
itself, and then
the compliance
documentation, which
is essentially your test
protocols, et cetera,
et cetera.
And as you can imagine now
if you had 47 requirements
with can set, and then
by the end-- [? Uonna ?],,
what would you say the
number of requirements
that we ended up with at the
end in A2 were closer to 100,
right?
Most people were around 80, 90.
OK, now imagine--
the good thing is
if you can do
tests that actually
check multiple requirements
at once, that's a good thing.
If you can do tests
that help you verify
multiple requirements
through the same tests,
you can save some money.
But the whole testing strategy,
the contractual requirements
that Volcker was mentioning,
it's a big, big, big deal.
It's a really critical
part of system engineering.
OK.
So in terms of the
lifecycle phases
where this fits in,
most of this activity
happens during phase D.
So you remember this was
the NASA lifecycle model,
and so phase D is system
assembly, integration, test,
and launch.
So much of the testing that
we talked about happens
during phase D. So the system
has been fully designed,
it's been assembled,
it's been integrated
the way we talked
about last week,
and now you're really putting
this system through its paces.
And so this phase D is
intense, it's expensive.
And if something goes
wrong, it sends you back
to the drawing board often.
And you have to do--
you have to figure out whether
a failed test, a failed
verification, is a showstopper.
If it is, then you have
to redesign the system,
you have to retest.
But if it's a minor
thing, then you
might be able to
request a waiver
and you can say, OK, we didn't
achieve this requirement,
or we failed this test, but
we think it's a minor issue.
And instead of holding
up the program,
we're going to get a
waiver for it, which
means you get an
exemption essentially,
and you can move on.
And whether or not a waiver can
or cannot be granted is a big
deal and that goes
under risk management,
which we'll talk about
in a few minutes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I had a question on--
so if you're a
system integrator,
and you created statements
of work for other people
to procure a large
optic, or something,
they go and build that
[INAUDIBLE] requirements,
and then they do all the
verification and testing,
and then they provide
all that documentation.
And then like from my experience
with anything like procurement
out stuff, that comes
back in your in house,
and you go to assemble
it, and you essentially
do a lot of that
verification and testing
again to double
check that supplier.
There is a little bit of
a conflict of interest,
obviously, with that
supplier doing the work
and also verifying
their own work.
Is there any good way
to get around that?
So it seems like a
very expensive process.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So my
experience-- basically,
you're talking about
separation of powers.
The good suppliers, they
will have internally
separation of powers.
In other words,
the people that are
doing the testing
and the Q&A, they're
usually people who really enjoy
finding mistakes and faults.
And that's why when I'm saying--
I'm trying to be diplomatic
when I said it, but people even
in software, people who
do software verification,
they love to find bugs.
They love to find problems,
because that's their job.
And so the good suppliers,
it's in their own self-interest
not to do shortcuts.
Now if you don't
trust that, and you
do all your same
testing and Q&A again,
that's a duplication of effort.
The way I've seen
that done effectively
is that you, as a
customer, say you're
going to buy the subsystem
or the engine for,
example, from it.
What you do is you
send liasion people,
you send
representatives, who are
knowledgeable people to the
supplier while the testing is
being done.
And so they're present when
the testing has been done.
They're very involved with it.
And therefore, you don't
have to do it twice.
So there are ways around this.
OK, so what I did here is
just search for the word test
and the list of milestones.
And where does it come up?
So the first time it really
comes up in a major fashion
is at the CDR. OK, so let
me just read this to you.
So the CDR demonstrates
the maturity of the design
and is appropriate
to support proceeding
with full scale fabrication,
assembly, integration,
and tests.
So in other words,
even at the CDR
you're blessing
the final design,
you should say
something at the CDR
about how the
testing will be done.
In fact, test planning
often is way before the CDR.
But at the CDR, you
should you should really
talk about the testing.
Then we have
so-called TRR, which
is a test readiness review.
And so for each major test,
you would have a separate TRR.
The TRR ensures that the test
article, hardware software,
the facilities, the support
personnel, the test procedures
are ready for testing data
acquisition reduction, meaning
data post-processing
and control.
And then at the system
acceptance review, the SAR,
that's when you
essentially transfer
the ownership of the asset.
And that's at the SAR,
at the system acceptance
review, that you're
going to review,
not just the product
and its documentation,
but all the test
data, the analyses
that support verification.
So at CDR, you say this
is the testing we'll do.
At the test review
itself, you say
everything is ready for
the tests to happen,
and then you do them.
And at the system
requirements review
you look backwards and you say,
what tests actually happen?
What's the documentation?
What were the results?
Are we ready to
own the asset now?
Does that does that make sense?
OK, so with that in mind, let's
talk about testing itself.
What kind of testing
there are, and so testing
is one of the four
methods of verification.
And it's the one that we
often spend the most money on.
So this is from the
handbook, section 5.3.
This is basically an
alphabetic list of the testing
that we typically do.
And I'll just
highlight a few here,
and then I have a
group exercise for you.
So aerodynamic testing,
burn-in testing,
which is often done
with electronics.
Make sure that you use you
burn-in your electronics,
you get them running at the
right conditions, drop testing,
pressure testing, pressure
limits, thermal testing,
G-loading, human factors
testing, thermal testing,
manufacturing random defects--
that's when you do
nondestructive inspection--
thermal cycling, vibration
testing, and so forth.
So this is 20 or 30
types of testing.
And then within each
there's even subtypes,
so there's a lot of
different-- and there's
a whole industry actually
that is primarily
focused on providing
test equipment, sensors,
data logging equipment.
It's a big industry not just
in aerospace, but throughout.
OK, so I'd like to do a little
turn to your partner exercise.
And the question is I want to
ask you what kind of testing
have you been
involved in the past.
And if this was like in product
design, product development,
that's fine.
If it was for an internship,
but even at the University
itself, if you did
some experimental work
and experimental testing as part
of research, that's fine too.
You can talk about that too.
So what kind of testing have
you been involved in the past?
What was the purpose
of the testing?
What were the challenges?
What went well?
What were the results?
Maybe if it didn't go
well, talk about that too.
All right, good.
So let's see, we're going
to go back and forth.
So who wants to
start here at MIT?
Who has a good story to tell?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I worked
on the ground station
side of the Lunar Laser
Communication Demonstration
program that recently flew.
So I was involved in
assembling an integration,
but also doing verification
testing in the lab
and at our field
site, but then we
did validation when we
be moved out to the field
site in New Mexico.
So I was involved in the whole
process and it was neat to see.
And we had to go
into the clean room
a few times to adjust
the optics, because we
saw that there weren't
meeting requirements.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
The reflector that
was left by the
astronauts, are you
using the reflector that
was left on the surface?
AUDIENCE: No, this was--
we were using just
like [INAUDIBLE]
like optical alignment
stuff in the lab.
And then when we were
out at the field site,
we were utilizing
guidestars to align optics.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So what was--
what went well?
Was there a big difference
between indoor and outdoor?
What surprised you
in these tests?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so once you can do
the alignment of the
individual telescopes which
were 20 inches in
diameter, you can
do that well in the laboratory,
but then every time you
assemble and
disassemble the system,
you change the alignment of
them relative to each other.
So there was a lot
of attention paid
to making sure that we could
replicate the alignment
to a certain extent.
So that was very difficult in a
laboratory setting to get done,
but once we did that,
we were able to have
fair confidence that when
we were out in the field
that we could match that.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Very good, very good.
What about EPFL?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
did an internship
in an aluminum-roll
product factory.
So basically, I was doing
natural science there.
And there was a whole
bunch of tests to do.
And well, all the tests
was about heat treatments
and different tempering.
And actually, the alloy that was
already produced in the factory
was not the best of
what we can have of it.
And it [? applied ?] to
change the [INAUDIBLE]
with the heat treatment
for a few seconds,
naturally, on the
line of production.
Adding this amount of
time was totally critical
because it was continuous.
And the rolled
aluminum, if it spends
a bit more time in the
oven, it would melt.
And that's a bit like for
the Swiss plane, actually.
Like I discussed
with my boss, saying
that we should maybe change
the original power meter.
But at the end, it was really
critical to change something
on the line because it
could have cost a lot,
like in the modification of the
oven or the general machine.
PROFESSOR: So were
those tests successful?
Were these
heat-treatment changes
eventually implemented
on the line?
Or did the tests reveal that
it would be too difficult?
AUDIENCE: Unfortunately,
I don't know because I
finished my internship before.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, you should find
out whether it worked out
in the end.
Very good.
Back to MIT, any other examples
people want to mention?
Test experiences?
Yes please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We bought
the CASA-295.
It's a small cargo aircraft.
And we get we got involved
in the development
of its simulator.
It was pretty different,
the simulator.
Because as the aircraft
has no fly-by wiring,
it is pretty light.
So lots of hydraulics
to de-motion.
And they brought the flight
model from the factory.
And we applied the flight
model to the simulator.
But it was not real enough.
So we had to go for flying,
like 60 test flying points.
And we have to go
back to the simulator
to apply these points to tailor
the simulator to meet reality.
PROFESSOR: I see.
So the purpose of this
testing-- because the plane
itself had already been
certified, it sounds like.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: It's Spanish, right?
Spanish airplane?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: You tested
it specifically
to get flight dynamics
and other data to then
tune the simulator to be
more reflective of reality.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Because the flight
model from the factory
was not close to reality at all,
PROFESSOR: Very, very
cool, very interesting.
So different purpose, of not
testing for certification
of the first airplane, because
it had already been certified,
but to get the simulator to
be matching more closely.
AUDIENCE: It was development
for the simulator.
Because it was sold afterwards
as a type delta simulator.
So it was the development
of the simulator.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Great, thank you
for that example.
This all sounds pretty good.
Anybody involved
in test failures?
You know, things
that didn't go well?
Yes, [? Narik? ?]
AUDIENCE: Well, it was an
interesting experience.
We were designing a
wind turbine that we
were 3-D printing in undergrad.
And we had certain requirements
on the wind turbine.
And we were supposed to test
in the wind tunnel afterwards.
What happened was that the wind
turbine matched our performance
prediction fairly closely.
But the generator and the
electrical power system
that the test
operators consisted of
wasn't designed to
handle the current
that we were outputting.
So we caused a small fire.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[LAUGHS]
So this was the test
equipment itself?
AUDIENCE: The test equipment.
PROFESSOR: Not the artifact
you were testing failed--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: --but the
test equipment around it,
because overload.
AUDIENCE: The
interesting point was
that we had no control
over the test equipment.
It was managed by
the university.
So within the requirements
that they gave us,
the power output possible
didn't match what they had.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
Great example.
So the test equipment
and the test artifact
need to be matched to
the test conditions.
Excellent, good.
I do hope that you those
of you that have not
had a lot of test experience,
that you get to experience it.
It's a lot of work,
slow, tedious.
But in many cases, despite
modeling and simulation,
there's still a big role
to play for actual testing.
OK, so let's talk
about aircraft testing.
Typically we distinguish
between ground testing
and flight testing.
Weights and balance,
I had some experience
with this on the F-18 program.
You think this is the most
trivial testing there could
possibly be, you just put
an airplane on a scale
and that's it.
Well, it turns out it's actually
more involved than you think.
First of all,
airplanes are very big.
They're heavy, multi-tons.
And typically it's
not just one scale.
You have several scales you
put on the landing gear.
So the scales need to
be properly calibrated.
If you have differences
in calibration
of the different scales,
you have an issue.
You need to determine the mass.
Not just the mass, but the CG.
And then the most
difficult thing
to experimentally determine,
at least in a 1G field,
is the inertia matrix, if you
need to experimentally get
the inertia matrix.
Do you remember
your Ixx, Ixy, Iyy?
The inertia matrix is tricky
because you typically then
have to suspend the airplane.
And just the presence of the
cables and the suspension
will pollute the
real inertia matrix.
And you have to subtract out
the effect of the suspension
system.
So something that seems super
trivial, weights and balances--
you just stand on the scale
in the morning, there it is--
is actually very tricky.
And there are people,
that's all they do.
They do weights
and balance testing
for spacecraft, aircraft.
And it's basically a science.
Engine testing, I'll
show you some pictures.
This is done in what's
called the Hush House.
So Hush House is
heavily insulated.
You run an engine through
all of its test conditions,
its operational conditions.
And then you integrate
it into the airplane
and you run it outdoors.
Fatigue testing, this has been
a big issue on the Swiss F-18.
But in general, making
sure that the airplane
can satisfy all the static
and dynamic structural load
conditions.
Avionics checkout, this
is very, very involved.
As we get more
and more displays,
mission-control computers,
all of the avionic suite
needs to be checked out.
Essentially every function,
every button, every menu item
needs to be tested.
And the tricky thing
is interactions
among different
pieces of avionics.
So you can't just test
each box in isolation.
You also have to look
at the interactions
of different pieces of
avionics, the flight control
software, or the
flight software that
is loaded in each of these
avionics boxes needs to be
in the right configuration.
It's a very big
combinatorial challenge
to do avionics
checkout these days.
And then finally,
pre-flight testing.
So this is everything you can do
on the ground, run the engines,
taxi with the
airplanes, basically
turn all the equipment on,
turn it off, do the cycling.
You could do a lot of testing
before you actually fly.
Flight testing itself falls
into different categories.
So flight performance
testing, rate of climb,
range, can you meet each point
in your prescribed performance
envelope?
Stability and control, this
is where test pilots typically
earn their living
putting airplanes
into stall conditions,
recovering from stalls,
trimming.
Flutter testing is a big deal.
So flutter is a phenomenon
whereby at high speeds
you have a coupling between
the structural deformations
of the airplane and the actual
excitation of, for example,
the wings.
Flutter can be very dangerous.
If you hit a resonance
at high speed
you can actually
destroy the airplane
because of an instability.
So flutter testing is also
very, very interesting
and very tricky.
And then finally,
this is primarily
for military airplanes, weapons
testing, both guns, missiles,
bombs, live fire testing--
sometimes also using
airplanes that are towed--
simulated targets, and then LO
stands for a Low Observability.
So this is essentially
all the new generation
of military airplanes have
measures to reduce their radar
signature, or even make them
invisible or quasi-invisible
to radar.
And you know, a lot of
this stuff is classified.
But actually checking that an
airplane is invisible on radar
or has truly low
observability, there's
a lot of testing
involved in that.
And that's also quite
expensive and very involved.
So let me show you
just some pictures
that I've collected
over the years.
This is a wind
tunnel test model.
This is a model
that was developed
as part of the F-18 program.
This is about 1995, vintage.
This model, it's a
subsonic wind tunnel model.
And you can see in
yellow, you have
all these probes and radomes
and things like this.
So it's basically to check
whether any modifications you
make to the airplane will affect
its performance in airflow.
This is for wind tunnel testing.
This model, by the way,
just building this model
is about half a million dollars.
It's very accurate.
It's very precise.
This is a picture--
yes?
Go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Is that model
full scale or half scale?
PROFESSOR: No it's, I want to
say, like 1/8 scale, something
like this.
Yeah.
OK, here's the Hush House
that I was talking about.
This is in St. Louis.
So you can see that the
airplane is not painted yet.
And only one engine at a time.
So the engine is being, in this
case, with full afterburner,
you can see the airplane itself
is secured with these chokes
here.
And there's load
cells in these chokes.
So as you fire up
the engine, you
can measure the thrust by
the load cells that are
attached to these chokes here.
You also see that there's
these cables running
in and out of the airplane.
So all the sensors,
everything, and the engine
is put through its full
different operating profiles.
And a lot of sensor
data is recorded
to make sure that the engine
responds appropriately,
it has the right thrust for
the right throttle setting,
the fuel consumption, all the
temperatures in the engine,
that everything is
nominal, essentially.
Live Fire Testing, this is a
Maverick missile being fired,
an air-to-ground missile.
As you can imagine, there are
special ranges and test sites
for doing this kind of work.
So in the US, one of the most
well known as China Lake,
out in California.
You have to reserve months
and sometimes years ahead.
So if you want to do like
a live fire test campaign,
you have to reserve the
range at least 18 months
to 2 years ahead of time.
Because a lot of other services,
a lot of other programs
are using the same facilities.
In Europe, it's a little harder.
Definitely in Switzerland,
because the country
is so small and dense
and highly populated,
you can't test live
missiles in Switzerland.
You can do guns, air to ground.
But in order to do
missile testing, typically
that's done here in the US,
or in a more limited fashion,
in Scandinavia, like in
Sweden, in northern Sweden,
there are some test
ranges up there.
This is the most expensive
kind of testing you can do.
So a single test like
the one shown here,
a single test like
this will probably
cost several million dollars.
Not just the airplane
and the weapon itself,
but all the test
procedures, the protocols,
airplanes that observe it
from all kinds of angles.
It's very, very involved.
And because it's
so expensive, you
will typically only do
it for something new
that you haven't done before.
Either a new weapon,
or a new weapon
integrated on a new
platform and so forth.
And obviously, it's
very interesting.
But it's very involved.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are they
just testing accuracy,
Or that the two
things work together?
What are they
looking for, really?
PROFESSOR: The
first thing you look
for is does the weapon fire?
So do you have all
the electronics?
All the signals?
The wire bundles?
Did you get it right?
Is there an end-to-end
functionality?
That's number one.
Number two, safety.
Does the weapon separate
properly from the aircraft?
The worst thing that
can happen to you
is if you release the weapon and
it collides with the airplane.
And so you can see, the various
angles and release conditions
are very tightly prescribed.
And so there's a separation,
has to be proper.
And then the third, of
course, is accuracy.
So within each of
these tests, there
are multiple sub-objectives
that you would test for.
But safety always comes first.
OK, any questions?
This was a little bit
military-aviation heavy.
If you're testing, whether it's
a CASA airplane or a new Airbus
or Boeing commercial airplane,
many, many months of testing.
They actually fly the routes.
You'll fly New York to
Singapore, to London.
You would actually
fly the real routes.
You would record
fuel consumption,
a lot of parameters.
Some of this testing
is not very exciting.
It's many, many, many,
many hours in the air.
But the key is that you have a
lot of instruments and sensors
during these tests that you may
not have during regular flight
operations, to really make
sure there's no surprises.
The airplane flies at least
as good as the requirements
that you promised
your customers.
And even then, when
you think about what
happened to the
Dreamliner, the 787
had a lot of battery problems.
Because they used a lot
of lithium ion batteries.
There were overheating issues.
Some of these problems
didn't show up in testing.
They only showed up
in early operations,
once you had a fleet going.
So it's not a guarantee
because you're
doing a lot of testing
that you're going
to catch all the problems.
But you want to catch
as many as you can.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So my question
was about the risk
posture for larger airliners,
for Boeing, the Airbuses.
So for military aircraft,
there is an escape method
for the pilot.
But for these larger
aircraft, how much analysis
do they do before they
decide to go ahead and put
a person inside?
They do fly by wire beforehand?
Is that possible. for
such large aircraft?
PROFESSOR: So that's
where the ground testing,
pre-flight testing
becomes very important.
So you basically taxi
for many, many hours.
All the flight control
surfaces, all the engine,
you have the Hush House testing.
So you essentially
try to do as much
as you can on the ground before
you do the maiden flight.
All right, let's
move to spacecraft.
And it's kind of
a similar thing.
You can distinguish
the ground testing
versus on-orbit testing.
So the ground testing is really
not that different, weights
and balance.
The biggest thing is if
your satellite is heavier
than the launch capability
of the launcher,
you have a real problem.
So the mass constraint is
even tighter in spacecraft.
Then, a lot of testing on
antenna and communications.
This is typically done
in anechoic chambers
in the near field, and then
later in the far field.
Vibration testing,
that's the shake part.
Thermal and vacuum-chamber
testing, that's the bake part.
And then you also have
pre-launch testing,
so off-pad and on-pad.
Off-pad testing is the
satellite or the spacecraft
has already been shipped
to the launch site,
and it's hooked up.
Like a patient in
the hospital, it's
hooked up to a lot of cables and
power and cooling and so forth.
And then when it's on the
pad, it's pretty limited.
So on the pad means the
satellite or the spacecraft
is already integrated
into the launch vehicle.
It's on the launchpad.
And then that amount of testing
you can do is very limited.
So that's when we say
off-pad, on-pad is,
is the spacecraft
already been integrated
on the launcher or not?
Once you launch to orbit,
you got your eight minutes
of terror.
And hopefully the
launch goes well
and the spacecraft is released
into its initial target orbit.
And then you do a lot of other
tests, like thruster testing.
Can you do station keeping?
Can you turn on and
off the thrusters?
You deploy all of your
mechanisms, your antennas,
your scientific instruments,
and then your communications,
communication and instruments.
And we'll talk more next
week, but this typically
is called commissioning.
You're commissioning a
spacecraft before you actually
turn it over to the users.
And that commissioning
phase could
be anywhere from a few days
to several weeks, or even
a couple months.
And again, you don't want
to randomly put commands
into your spacecraft.
These test sequences,
deployment sequences,
are very, very, very
carefully worked out.
Every command,
the order in which
you send the commands have
been worked out ahead of time.
They've been simulated.
And all you want to see
here is confirmation
that the spacecraft
behaves as planned.
Some pictures, so this is what
typical spacecraft integration
testing looks like.
So this is in a
cleanroom environment.
You have people in bunny suits.
And the idea is to not
damage the spacecraft
while you're doing the testing.
This is a picture of the
Clementine spacecraft.
This is a radio frequency
anechoic chamber testing.
So you see these
funny cones here.
These are essentially
foam cones.
And the idea is to
prevent multipath
to prevent echoes
in the test chamber,
to test all of
the antennas, EMI,
electromagnetic interference
and compatibility,
charging and discharging
of the spacecraft.
This is one of
the failure modes,
is that you have high
electrostatic charges that
build up on a
spacecraft, create a lot
large voltage potential
across the spacecraft.
Some spacecraft have
failed because of that.
So all of these things you want
to test in a very controlled
environment.
James Webb Space Telescope,
I'll send you a link.
I'll send you a
link through email.
There's a simulation of
this on-orbit deployment.
It truly is amazing.
This spacecraft will be
launched in a box, essentially.
And the deployment sequence is
very carefully choreographed.
First, typically, you
deploy your solar panels
because you need power.
Because you're only running
on battery initially.
So if your battery
runs out before you've
had a chance to deploy
your solar panels
and get fresh power into
it, you're in big trouble.
So typically,
solar panels first.
Then communications.
And then you start deploying
the other subsystems.
So for James Webb,
also very tricky,
is this-- this is
called the Sunshield.
It's essentially thin
layers of insulation.
And the geometry
is very important.
The primary mirror,
the secondary mirror,
all these things
need to be deployed
with very, very high precision.
And it's even to the point where
this particular spacecraft is
so lightweight that it cannot
support its own weight in a 1G
gravity field.
So there is no way
to test, end-to-end,
the full deployment
sequence on Earth.
The first time it will
happen is in orbit.
Now, they've tested sub
sequences or scaled models.
For example, the
Sunshield has actually
been deployed at a smaller
scale in a 1G field,
but never the full thing.
So this will be kind of scary,
after an $8 billion investment.
So let's hope for
the best, 2018.
So testing is good,
testing, testing, testing.
But testing also
has its caveats.
So caveat means
limitations, essentially.
So testing is critical,
but it's very expensive.
Think about test rigs,
test chambers, sensors,
DAQ is Data
Acquisition Equipment.
All this stuff is
very expensive.
And if you can reuse things
between different programs,
that helps.
But still, how much testing
should you do of components?
So one of the
comments, who mentioned
the vendor, the supplier?
One of you.
You talked about it.
And this is a key question.
Do you trust the parts that
come from your vendors?
Or do you retest
everything yourself?
Calibration of
sensors and equipment,
if you've done some
testing and you
forgot to calibrate your
displacement sensors,
your thrust sensors,
you didn't calibrate
them or they're
out of calibration,
that's a big problem.
That's a big problem.
So before you start
your tests, make sure
that all your sensors
are properly calibrated,
or you can get the
wrong conclusions.
This is a mantra
that's well-known.
Test as you fly,
fly as you test.
Fundamentally, this means
that the configuration
of your item--
a spacecraft, aircraft,
medical device--
the one that you test should be
the same configuration as what
you're actually going to fly.
And it's often failures occur
when the test went well,
but then somebody
tinkered with it
and modified it before
it actually flew.
And that change actually
caused a big problem.
So make sure that
your test conditions
reflect the actual operations
as closely as possible.
Simulated tests, what
do we mean by this?
So simulated tests
use dummy components.
Maybe your full spacecraft
or aircraft isn't ready yet,
you don't have all the pieces.
So you can still
start testing, but you
have to replace the missing
pieces with dummy components.
At least, they should reflect
the right mass distribution.
But maybe you can do more.
Simulated operations,
so the 0G versus 1G,
is it representative?
And then, what's often true is
that you pass all your tests
and then you still have
failures in practice.
And the failures often happen
outside of the test scenarios
that you had tested.
So you have to be
ready for that.
But try to avoid that.
So here's from Appendix E.
This is called a Validation
Requirements Matrix.
Essentially what this
is, is an organized way
to organize your V&V
activities, in terms
of what's the activity?
What's the objective?
Which facility or lab
will you do it in?
What phase?
Who's in charge?
And what are the
expected results?
It's pretty straightforward.
It's just a table to
organize these activities.
And then appendix I is
your more formal V&V plan.
This is a suggested
outline for it.
And I'll just say this.
The degree to which you take
Verification and Validation
seriously and the
resource you make
available for it are
critical for success.
So how many dedicated
Q&A personnel?
What is the interaction
in working with suppliers?
Are you planning
ahead for these tests?
How close are you getting to
actual end-to-end functional
testing?
Can you piggyback on existing
facilities and equipment?
How well do you document
all the outcomes
and follow up with
discrepancies?
And my last comment here is this
work is often not glamorous,
except for some of the
very cool flight testing
that I showed you.
Most of this work
is really hard work.
It's very detail-oriented.
It's not glamorous.
But it's essential.
If you cut corners, you
often pay the price for it.
So any comments or questions?
We'll take a short break,
like a five-minute break.
But any questions about testing,
verification, validation?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Not really
a question, but I
wanted to say that also,
flight testing is not so fancy.
I mean, many people think it is.
Well, if they actually
fly, maybe it's fun.
But there are not that many.
And you need to prepare
them weeks and weeks ahead.
And it's actually
very, very boring.
Because you need to make sure
that you don't waste time
at all.
Well, at least you can
waste a little bit more time
in the lab.
So it's very stressing
and not so fun to fly.
PROFESSOR: Do have
experience with this?
AUDIENCE: I wasn't
flying, because you
need to be certified.
But I was preparing.
And I think it's even worse
than testing in the lab.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
Which airplane, or which
system were you involved with?
AUDIENCE: I was in with
the power plane system
for [? Airbus, ?] particularly.
And the aircraft was an A330.
PROFESSOR: A330, OK.
Great.
But I think it's healthy
to have this experience.
It really makes you humble.
And you also see, for the things
in design, did you design well?
Did you design for testability?
Really, I highly recommend
for every one of you
to try to get on some
kind of test campaign,
at least once in your career,
because it's eye opening.
So thank you for that comment.
Any comments at EPFL?
Any of the students?
[? Voelker? ?] Did you
want to add something?
Katya?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
guess the comment is,
it seems like
sometimes you can meet
all of the requirements in
the verification process.
But when you get to
the validation part,
for example, maybe the
customer has some expectation
that the range for
the time of flight
would have been on
the maximum edge
and you were on
the minimum edge.
But actually, it seems
like sometimes you
can meet all the requirements
but they're still
not going to be happy.
When do you find
that middle ground?
And it's going to be constant,
to continue iterating this
over and over again.
Do you try to involve them
earlier on, during the testing
process too?
How do you handle
that, that difference?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
tricky, you know?
So that's when you do need
contractual agreements
in place.
You need to have the
requirements, baseline.
contractual agreements.
And hopefully, any
problems that occur
will not lead to some
kind of legal dispute.
But sometimes
that's unavoidable.
But as a designer, as a
manufacturer, unless you
have agreements in place
and clear baseline,
how do you decide in the
end, is it successful
or is it not successful?
And if there's problems, try
to isolate these problems
and say, OK here, by and
large, the testing went well.
But we have like,
three, four, five issues
that need to be addressed.
And you can tackle
these issues one by one.
But if you don't have a
contract in place that's
really a good contract, if you
don't have a clear requirements
baseline, and then
if you don't have
a good relationship
with your customer,
you're setting yourself
up for big, big problems.
[? Voelker? ?] Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There is also the
one big difference
between commercial operators
or commercial customers
that are becoming
more and more frequent
compared to the
institutional ones.
And often I remember, for some
of the [? Global ?] [? Store ?]
[? Iridium ?] series, the
customer was only accepting
the hardware six months after
they had been commissioned
in orbit.
So there you have a
validation that is still
your responsibility in orbit.
You can't go and fix it,
but it still has to work.
And he was retaining up to
10% of the full contact value,
even up to the N
minus-2-tier-level suppliers,
until he was satisfied
it was working in orbit.
So these considerations, it's
really the proof of the pudding
when you have to test this
up there and can't fix it.
So there's no recall
of a satellite
constellation, like, sorry we
messed up with the software.
It's not possible there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And of course, those
terms and conditions
you've probably
negotiated years before.
So you've got to be careful.
That's where risk management,
which is actually--
thank you, [? Voelker, ?]
for that comment.
Let's take a short break.
And then we'll talk about risk
management, which is really
what this ends up being.
So let me talk about
risk management.
And this is actually quite
prominent in the System
Engineering Handbook.
This is right in the middle
here of your System Engineering
Engine, Technical Risk
Management, Section 13.
Why is it important?
So first of all, what is risk?
So risk is the probability
that a program or project
will experience some
undesired effect or event.
And then the consequences
or impact or severity
of that undesired
event should occur.
And so think of risk as the
product of probability times
impact.
And the undesired events could
come from a number of things,
technical, programmatic.
So cost overruns,
schedules slippage,
safety mishaps, health
problems, malicious activities--
cybersecurity is a
big thing these days--
environmental impact,
failure to achieve
the scientific or technological
objectives or success criteria.
And so technical
risk management is,
therefore, an organized
systematic risk-informed
activity centered around
decision making to proactively
identify, analyze, plan, track,
control, communicate risks
to increase the likelihood
of success of a program.
And so what risk really
does is measure the future
uncertainties of achieving
your program goals-- technical,
cost, schedule goals--
and think of risks
in a holistic way,
all aspects of the
technical effort,
technology maturity,
supplier capabilities,
performing against
plan, and so forth.
And so the idea of risks is
that risks have some root cause.
There's something that
gives rise to risks.
And then the actual
quantification of risks
happens in terms of
likelihood and consequences,
which are kept separate,
separate dimensions.
So the first thing
to think about
is where do risks come from?
Where is the source of risks?
And I want to show
you a couple of models
for thinking about this.
The first one is this
idea of layers of risk,
that there are layers of risk.
And I want to credit
one of my colleagues
here at MIT, Don Lessard from
the Sloan School, who really
developed this
Layer of Risk Model
and applied it to
different industries.
So there's a version of this
for the oil and gas industry.
You could make a version for
medical, medical technologies.
So this is the version
for Mars missions,
so if you're designing a new
Mars mission, a new Mars Rover.
So you have, in
the bullseye here,
the narrow interpretation is
technical or project risk.
So the airbag technology.
If you're using airbags for
deployment, will it work?
The rover/motor
performance, are you
going to have software bugs?
Those are the risks we
typically think about.
And the idea is you
have high influence
over these risks as a system
engineer, as a project manager.
Then you have a layer
around it, which we call
industry or competitive risks.
Will your contractors perform?
Will you have budget stability?
And then there's sort of
more country and fiscal risk.
So in the US, we
have a budget cycle.
We have four-year
administrations.
Will you get your budget?
What is the priorities between
human and robotic space
exploration?
And then working with
international partners.
And then there's
another layer of risk,
which are called market risks.
So if you think in Mars
missions, who's your market?
Well, the science community
and maybe the public.
So will these missions
hold their attention?
Are there new
science requirements?
We discovered there's water,
probably flowing water on Mars,
maybe with a lot of
perchlorates in it.
It's not pristine water.
But that could change the
priorities for your mission.
And then finally, the most outer
is what we call natural risk.
So this would be things
like cosmic radiation,
micrometeorites, uncertainties
in the atmospheric density
of Mars as you're doing
entry descent and landing.
And you have very low influence.
That doesn't mean you can't
protect yourself or take
measures to deal
with these risks.
But fundamentally, the
occurrence or the probability
is something you can't
really do much about.
So that's one way to
think about risks.
And the seeds of risks
is in these layers.
I know this is very high
level, but I find this
to be a pretty useful model.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So this
references the influence
you have, not necessarily
the amount that each of these
are a risk to the program?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
And That will be
program specific.
Just the stuff that's
in the bullseye here,
you can do a lot
about it, and perhaps
both in terms of
probability and impact.
And then as you
move further out,
there's less and less influence
you have as a system engineer,
as a project manager.
Here's another way to organize
your thinking around risks.
And this is around
the "Iron" Triangle
and project management.
We talk about the
"Iron" Triangle
of cost, schedule, and risk.
And we call it "Iron"
because the idea
is that if you constrain
all three too tightly,
it can be very difficult.
And it's also referred to
as the triple constraint
in project management.
So the three dimensions here
are technical risks, cost risks,
and schedule risk.
And in the center we
have programmatic risk,
which means it's kind of the
combination of all three.
And the idea that even if
you do a great job on keeping
your budget under
control, schedule,
and you're meeting your
technical objectives,
you can still fail because
the program as a whole
isn't doing the right thing.
Or the market that
you had been targeting
is no longer really attractive
by the time you launch.
The key idea here is that
these risk categories are not
independent of each other.
So let me mention a
couple of examples.
So cost risk might
limit your funds.
And that could, in itself,
induce technical problems which
cause you further cost risk.
So one of the big initiatives
at NASA in the '90s
was the faster, better,
cheaper program.
We're going to launch
more missions, cheaper.
And out of 10 missions,
maybe 2 or 3 will fail.
And then seven will succeed.
But we'll get more value
out of this as a portfolio.
Unfortunately, it
didn't work very well.
Because when the one,
two, or three missions
fail out of your portfolio,
the media and the public
focuses on the failures rather
than the aggregate value
of the whole portfolio.
And eventually, that's
probably the main reason
why faster, better,
cheaper was abandoned.
So for example, we just
talked about testing.
If you have a very
limited budget,
what is the first thing
people typically cut out?
What's the first thing to go?
Testing.
Testing is very important.
Sam asked me during
the break, what's
your typical budget for
testing in V&V activities?
And in many programs,
it's very substantial,
you know, 40% of the
budget, maybe 30%,
40% of the budget easily.
And so you start
cutting out tests.
Well, what you do is you
introduce technical risk.
And if you have failures
because you didn't test,
that could cause you additional
rework and more cost.
Similar, schedule slips
can induce cost risk.
So as you slow down,
you have what's
known as the standing
army cost, right?
People are going to
charge to your program,
even if it's at a reduced level.
And that will also
increase your cost.
So lots of coupling here
between risk categories.
This is a very useful
Risk Management Framework.
It's essentially a
controls framework.
And the idea is you
start in the upper right.
You anticipate what can
go wrong in your program.
So that's risk identification.
You then analyze these risks,
in terms of prioritizing them,
which of these are important?
You plan to take action.
This is often called
risk mitigation.
You track these actions.
And then you correct any
deviations from your plan
and you communicate throughout,
and you cycle through this.
So typically, risk
management will
happen on a weekly basis,
a monthly basis, at least
quarterly basis
for big programs.
Now, how do you
actually do this?
First of all, the risk
ID and the assessment.
So the risks are
typically brainstormed.
So you think about risks.
You have to imagine all the bad
stuff that could happen to you
and your program,
the probability
that these things
will happen, and then
the impact or
consequence if they
do happen based on the
requirements, the cost,
the schedule, the product
and its environment.
And this is where
actually having
a mix of younger engineers
and more experienced engineers
really comes in handy.
The experienced
engineers, they will have
been through several programs.
They will have seen
failures in the past.
They will really be able
to point to potential risks
that less-experienced people may
ignore or just not understand
how important they could be.
So the next step, then,
is to aggregate these
into categories, typically not
more than 20-or-so categories
or risk items.
Projects often keep so-called
risk registers, which is just
a database or a list of risks.
If you have hundreds and
hundreds of risks in the risk
register, it's too much.
It's just a long
list and really it's
just a check-the-box exercise.
To really take risk
management seriously,
you have to focus
on few of the risks
that you think are important.
You score them based
on a combination
of opinions and data.
And you try to involve all
the stakeholders in the risk
management.
And eventually, risks
are placed on this matrix
of uncertainty and consequence.
So let me zoom in on the matrix.
There are many, many different
versions of the risk matrix.
This is one that
NASA typically uses.
And I like this particular
version for several reasons
that I'll explain.
But basically, the
way it works is
you have the two dimensions,
impact and probability.
So probability is how
likely is this to occur?
And then impact, if it does
occur, what will happen?
What's the consequence of that?
So of the two things that
I really like about it,
the first one is that
each of these levels,
there's actually some
definition behind it.
Not just guessing at the level,
but there's some criteria.
So for probability,
a level 3 means
it's about equally likely that
it will happen and not happen.
So a level 3 means
it's about 50/50,
whether this will
happen in your program.
And then 4 is very likely.
So maybe that's,
I don't know, 75%.
And then near-certainty
is like 90% or more.
Improbable is like 10%.
Unlikely is 20% to 30%,
something like this.
And then more importantly,
the impact so a level 1 impact
is negligible.
It has almost no impact.
A level 2 means your
mission performance margins
are reduced on the
technical side.
Do you remember margins?
I asked you to assign
margins in assignment A2?
So it means you're eating
into your reserves.
But you should still be able
to meet all your performance.
There should be
no visible impact.
Your safety cushion is less.
That's what level 2 means.
Number 3 means your
mission is degraded.
So you can still do the mission.
But you're not going to
hit all your targets.
4 is you lose the mission, but
the asset is still recoverable.
So maybe you could try
again in the future.
And then level 5 is a
catastrophic failure
that involves a loss of
mission and/or loss of crew.
On the cost side, you have
some thresholds for cost.
Obviously these numbers
have to be adjusted
for different programs.
A $10-million loss is a
huge thing in some program
and almost like pocket
change in other programs.
And then schedule, so a level
1 milestone would, for example,
be launch.
Good example of this was
the Mars Science Laboratory,
their Curiosity mission.
Originally it was supposed
to launch in 2009.
They missed that
deadline, mainly due
to problems with
cryogenic actuators.
They took a lot of the
blames, the actuators.
But there were a lot of
problems across the board.
They missed that launch window.
And they had to launch in 2011.
So that was considered, from
a programmatic standpoint,
a level 5 failure.
Because you missed your
main launch window and you
had to wait 26 months
for the next one.
So that's good.
Because now when you assign
a probability and impact,
you can really look
at these criteria.
And it's easier to do that
in a repeatable fashion.
The other thing is if you look
at the colors on the matrix,
you can see it
goes from 1, blue,
which means low risk, to 12,
which is the highest risk.
So there's 12 risk levels.
But when you look at
the matrix, there's
something peculiar about it.
So look closely at the colors.
And you'll see something
special about this matrix.
Anybody notice what
I'm talking about?
Let's see at EPFL, do you guys,
when you look at those colors,
at the matrix, do
you notice something?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It goes
from blue to red,
which is a light spectrum,
with the blue the lowest radio
waves, waves, and
red the highest ones.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's due to impact is
more serious than probability.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's asymmetric.
You see that?
It's asymmetric.
So the high-impact,
low-probability corner
is weighted more heavily
than the low-impact,
high-probability.
And that's intentional because
it's been shown in the past
that things that are not likely
to happen but if they happen,
they're really bad,
in the past, people
have sort of pushed that
away and ignored those.
So the purpose of this
asymmetry in this matrix
is to elevate the
low-probability, high-impact
events to be higher
in the risk level
so that people pay
more attention to it.
OK?
So most risk matrices don't
have that asymmetry in them,
but this one does.
[SNEEZES]
And I like it because of that.
Bless you.
So the question then is,
what do you do with this?
The idea is you do
your risk management.
You identify your risks.
You place them on this matrix.
And then you track each of
these risk items over time.
So here's your 12 risk
levels, between 1 and 12.
That's the y-axis.
And then on your
x-axis there's Time.
And for each of your risk
items, people might disagree.
Some people on your team
might say, hey, look,
this is not a big deal.
We've seen this before.
The impact is not big.
We have a quick fix for this.
We know how to deal with this.
And other people
disagree and say no, this
is very, very serious.
You have to take it seriously.
So the idea is that
for each risk item,
you have this
optimistic, expected,
and pessimistic estimate of
what is the true level of risk.
That's what these bars are.
And then you track it over time.
And depending on whether
you're before PDR or CDR,
you could have very
substantial risks.
And that's, I guess,
OK still, as long
as you find ways to
reduce the level of risk.
For example, by
doing extra testing,
by changing your design to
put in extra power margins,
bigger solar panels,
redundancy, for example.
There's a lot of
things you can do
to affect both the probability
and the impact, radiation,
extra shielding.
And so the idea is
that over time you're
going to reduce these risks
gradually below some threshold.
So this red line here is
like the acceptable threshold
of risks at that
point in the program.
And then as you get
closer to launch,
things should be
below the threshold.
And if it's below
this watch domain,
then you even don't track it.
You don't pay much
attention to it.
If it's above this red line,
you have a big problem.
You might have to stop the
program or do a major redesign,
or repeat a major milestone.
And some programs have been
canceled because they just
couldn't get these
risks under control.
So the idea is that
gradually you transition.
And you do this by actually
doing risk mitigation
around that risk
management cycle.
Now, the last thing
I will say here
is that every mission
that is worthwhile doing
is still going to have some
residual risk at the end.
The requirement is not
that all the risks are
at 0 in the lower-left corner.
You will launch, and you're
going to have residual risks.
And you just have
to accept those.
But you have to be
cognisant of this.
And this is really no different
in the automotive industry,
for example.
When you're developing a
new car or a medical device
and you're going to
launch it to the market,
if your requirement is 0 risk,
you will never sell anything.
You will never launch anything.
Because you will always
think of something bad
that could happen.
And there will always be
people saying it's too risky.
We can't do it.
So knowing how
much residual risk
you should be willing
to carry is a big part
of being a leader, being
a system engineer, really
understanding things.
And in the automotive
industry, there
are people whose primary job
they have is to do this work.
And they're called Quality
Engineers or Warranty
Engineers.
So the Warranty Engineers,
their job is twofold.
Before you launch a
vehicle to market,
it's actually ranking on this
particular vehicle or program,
what are the top 10 things that
could cause warranty planes
and problems in the future?
We don't know that they
will, but they might.
Right?
And then once a
vehicle goes to market
and reports are coming back
from users and from the fleet,
actually tracking
what these issues are
and then knowing when has
it hit a threshold where
you do need to do a recall,
you do need to do a retrofit,
this is a big part of it.
And it's really a big deal.
I mean, the amount of money that
automotive companies spend on
recalls every year is about the
same as what their profits are.
So if you could eliminate
recalls and warranty
claims altogether, you'd
basically double your profit.
And so depending
on what industry
you're in, whether it's
automotive, medical,
spacecraft, how much risk
and safety is involved,
this is more or less
emphasized in the industry.
But it's a big part, I
think, of system engineering
job, is to understand this.
This is, again, a flow diagram
for how to do this risk
management properly.
You have a Risk Management
Plan, your technical risk issues
that are placed on the
matrix, any measurements
or data you have.
And then how do you report this?
And then out of it
comes a mitigation plan,
a set of actions, technical
risk reports, and then
any work product from the
technical risk management.
And the idea is that
you repeat this process
on a regular basis.
And it's a big part of your
milestone reviews as well.
OK, so I'd like to spend a
few minutes on system safety.
I am not going to do this
justice because there's
a whole class here at MIT on
this, taught by Professor Nancy
Leveson.
By the way, who's
taken that class?
Or who's been thinking
about taking it?
About three, four of you.
So I'm just going to give you
a very quick exposure to this.
So this is a book that Professor
Leveson wrote several years
ago.
And she basically distinguishes
two kinds of failures.
Component failures, which
most people think about,
an axle broke or there
was a battery caught fire.
And clearly, component
failures are real
and they happen, single or
multiple component failures.
And usually there's
some randomness to them.
So most of the classic
accident investigation
techniques and safety techniques
focus on component failures.
But there's also component
interaction accidents
or failures which are
trickier, in a sense,
because you could
have a system that
has no single component
that's failed.
And yet, you had
a system failure.
And so it's the interactions
among components.
And this could be related
to interactive complexity
in coupling, more and more
computers and software,
and then the role of
humans and systems.
And this is really what
a lot of this is about.
So the traditional
safety thinking
is that component
failures, you need
to worry about the
component failures only.
So here's a classic example
of a sequence of events.
This is for a tank failure.
So in this case, we have a tank.
And there's moisture that
builds up in the tank.
And then corrosion,
essentially, as a result.
The metal gets weakened.
And under the operating
pressure of the tank, the tank
itself has been weakened
due to corrosion.
The operating pressure
causes a tank rupture.
And the tank rupture
then causes, essentially,
an explosion.
And fragments or
shrapnel from the tank
will be projected and then
cause equipment damage
or personnel injury.
And so in this linear
chain-of-events model,
the way you think about
safety is putting in barriers.
This is often also referred
as the Swiss cheese model.
if you take layers
of Swiss cheese--
and I guess it has to
be Emmentaler, right?
You guys know the
Emmentaler at EPFL?
Emmentaler is the one,
it's got the big holes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So you take
these slices of cheese.
And if you can
look at the cheese,
and there's actually
a hole right through,
then the accident can happen.
But if you put another
barrier in between,
you can't see through the cheese
and the accident is prevented.
That's the classical
thinking around system safety
is chain of events.
And then put barriers
between these.
And this is, I think, valid
for a very particular kind
of accidents, which are
these component accidents.
What Professor Leveson says in
her STAMP and STPA Framework
is a little different.
This is based on essentially
thinking about safety
as a lack of control of a
system, lack of control-ability
of a system.
And so if you think
about it this way,
I'm showing you
here a control loop.
In this case, you have
the actual system,
the actual process
that you're executing.
The controlled process is here.
You're sensing things about
that process, so temperature,
pressure, proper alignment.
And so one problem could be
your sensors are inadequate.
You're sensing the
wrong information.
And then here's your
controller model,
how should you
control the system?
So you have the wrong controller
or the wrong process model.
And then here's your actuators.
Are you issuing commands
at the right time?
Are you issuing
the right commands?
Or are you not
issuing commands when
you should be to the system?
And that feeds back into
the control process itself.
And so process inputs
could be wrong or missing.
You could have disturbances
into the process that are
unidentified or out of range.
And then eventually, if
this process goes unstable,
then you have a
failure or an accident.
So it's quite different.
It's essentially
thinking of this
as a control problem instead
of a chain-of-events problem.
And the argument here is
that for safety or failures
that involve a combination of
hardware, software and humans,
often this model is able
to be more complete,
in terms of identifying hazards
and potential mitigation
actions.
So I think we're out of time.
But I want I want to give
this to you as a homework
for thinking about this.
This is an accident that
happened earlier this year,
I guess, in July.
And this is the Virgin
Galactic crash that happened.
Virgin Galactic is one of
the space tourism companies.
And during a test
flight, the airplane
crashed because the copilot
unlocked the brake system.
So it has a kind of
feathering mechanism.
And the pilot
unlocked it too early
during a high-speed
flight phase.
So what I'd like you to
do, the link is here.
Just read the story.
There's a more lengthy accident
report that's come out.
I'd like you to just read this
quickly and then think about
how does this relate to risks?
How does it relate to
this particular model
of system safety?
So the System's
Theoretic View of Safety
is then that safety is an
emergent system property.
Accidents arise
from interactions
among system components--
physical, human, social--
constraint violation.
Losses are the result
of complex processes,
not simple chain of events.
And that most
accidents arise from--
you could have a system
that's quite safe when
you start operating it.
But over time it migrates
to an unsafe state.
Because sensors fail.
People start bypassing
safety procedures.
And gradually, it
migrates to high risk.
OK.
So the last thing I want
to talk about-- just
for a minute or two-- is the
FRR, the Flight Readiness
Review, which is one of
the later milestones.
And what happens
at the flight FRR?
Essentially, this is your last
chance to raise a red flag.
This is the last
milestone before launch.
Have all the V&V activities
been passed successfully?
Are there any waivers
that need to be granted?
What are the residual
risks we just talked about?
And then after the
FRR has passed,
you actually start
the countdown--
T minus X days, Y
hours, Z seconds--
to an actual launch, or a
product launch, whatever it is.
And then here's from the
handbook, the entrance
and success criteria for FRR.
Everything should have
been done at this point.
Your design, your
integration, your testing,
your operating procedure,
your people should be trained.
This is your last chance
to raise a red flag.
After the FRR, you're
essentially go for launch.
So the stakes are high.
OK, so a quick summary.
Verification and
validation are critical.
There's a distinction
between the two.
Verification is against the
requirements as written.
Validation is you go
back to your customer
and you test in a
real environment.
Testing, many different
kinds of testing.
It's a fundamentally
Q&A activity,
and it's really expensive,
but it needs to be done right.
Risk management, we
have different tools
like the risk matrix, risk
identification, mitigation.
And that's really where
the rubber meets the road,
in terms of the tension
between cost, scope, schedule,
and risk in projects.
System safety, think about not
just the chain of events model,
but this control's view as well.
STAMP/STPA is a particular
framework for this.
And if you're interested,
there's a whole class.
There's a whole
set of things you
can learn about just safety.
And then finally, FRR
is your last chance
to raise the red flag.
It's sort of the big
milestone before you go live
with your system.
OK?
So any last questions
or comments?
EPFL?
Yes, please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So after the
FRR you should have
finished your tests, right?
It's the limit?
PROFESSOR: Yes, you should
have finished your tests
except for the ones that you're
going to do, say, on orbit,
right?
AUDIENCE: Because I was
wondering, in the list
there is the go, no-go test.
And I'm wondering if it's
not related to the launch,
actually?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so the actual
launch itself, of course,
has the actual launch countdown.
And you can stop the launch.
So this is a review.
The FRR is more like a CDR.
So the countdown hasn't
actually started yet.
But if you successfully
pass the FRR,
that's when you
begin the countdown.
The official countdown starts.
And then you still have
a possibility, of course,
of stopping the launch.
But in terms of a formal
programmatic review,
this is your last chance.
AUDIENCE: I think the point
here is more about the what
is the system boundary?
If you consider the
system boundary being
the whole mission,
including the launch,
then obviously the
system will only
be finished when the mission
has finished phase EF.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And this FRR,
Flight Readiness Review,
is linked to the panel or
to the whole satellite,
specifically that you are
allowed to go forward and now
start the countdown issues.
And then all the other things.
Like, you'd extend the mission
boundaries to the whole space
program or to the whole
colonization of Mars,
it will be, obviously, later.